[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 12 juillet
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
dernière édition de la saison il ne
digère pas la fin à d'autolib une
vingtaine de maires de communes de
banlieue va déposer un recours devant le
tribunal administratif ces élus menée
par l'édile du chesnay philippe
brillault conteste l'arrêt définitif du
service programmée le 31 juillet
explication dans ce journal
et j - 2 avant la fête nationale et son
traditionnel défilé sur les champs
elysées cet événement se prépare dans
les yvelines sur la base de satory à
versailles nous avons suivi les
répétitions et puis l'excellent dans la
préparation de ce plat typique italien
sébastien si dole s'est classé sixième
au championnat du monde de pizza c'était
en juin dernier à naples dans le berceau
de cette spécialité à l'illinois qui
officie à garancière est notre invité
elle nous avons appris sa mort
aujourd'hui à des suites d'une longue
maladie le poète et c'est ici blinois
géant d'espère c'était un lundi à l'âge
de 97 ans est lauréat de l'académie
française auteur de nombreux recueils on
lui doit notamment le nom du département
des yvelines
il avait soufflé l'idée au premier
président du conseil général au moment
de la création de la collectivité en
1968 ce nom faisant référence à la forêt
des yvelines qui ceinturait autrefois
paris sg en espère sera inhumé mardi
prochain au cimetière de guyancourt une
vingtaine de communes de banlieue a
décidé de saisir la justice menée par le
maire du chesnay philippe brillault ces
villes vont déposer un recours devant le
tribunal administratif un recours pour
s'opposer à la fin d'autolib le service
est prévue la fin du service est prévue
le 31 juillet ces élus dénoncent
notamment un manque de concertation et
une décision brutale imposée par la
mairie de paris il refuse également de
payer une partie de la dette c'est du
service d'autopartage les précisions de
nicolas quirion ritz
leurs batteries a eu son plein et
promettent de ne rien lâcher les maires
de banlieues s'attaque à la mairie de
paris réunie au sein d'un collectif ils
vont saisir la justice pour s'opposer à
la résiliation du contrat autolib' avec
le groupe bolloré pour eux et leur porte
voix le maire du chéné la décision
validée par les élus du syndicat mixte
s'est faite sans véritable concertation
pas d'informations pas de communication
pas de participation en huis clos
et puis pas de document avant tout en
précipitations et comme par hasard en
plein été donc je rassure nos
administrés nous sommes là pour défendre
leurs intérêts bien évidemment financier
nous serons là cet été plusieurs recours
seront déposés devant le tribunal
administratif l'objectif des élus
empêcher l'arrêt du service le 31
juillet prochain
principal visé par ces recours la maire
de paris et la présidente du syndicat
autolib tout ceci est un fiasco
non pas du syndicat mais de
l'actionnaire majoritaire de la ville de
paris car il ya également ce problème de
gouvernance
est-ce que c'est madame hidalgo qui
préside le syndicat
ou est ce que c'est la présidente
actuelle la fin du contrat avec le
groupe bolloré a été décidée après les
annonces autour de la dette d'autolib
estimé à près de 300 millions d'euros en
2023 psa et renault pourrait prendre la
suite du marché de l'autopartage
franciliens fin mai plus de cent
cinquante mille personnes étaient
abonnées aux blue car une quinzaine de
personnes mobilisées hier devant le
rectorat à versailles parents d'élèves
professeurs et lycéens sont venus
manifester contre parcours sup une
mobilisation à l'appel de fo pour
demander l'abandon de ce système dans le
viseur le bilan pour eux négative de la
plateforme pour trouver une formation
dans le supérieur environ 133 1000
jeunes de terminale sont encore dans
l'attenté d'une réponse d'orientation
propos recueillis par ray car la ville
et mickaël millero nombre de lycées a
encore son sans affectation à la date
d'aujourd'hui donc à la date du 11
juillet ce qui n'est pas une situation
acceptable pour nous nous demandons à
être reçus par monsieur le recteur par
le cabinet de monsieur le recteur afin
de pouvoir porter les dossiers poser des
questions et y avoir des réponses
également sur la situation précise dans
notre département les yvelines et au
niveau de l'académie de versailles
également une délégation a bien été
reçue hier au rectorat elle n'a pas eu
selon ses représentants obtenu de
réponse satisfaisante de la part de la
direction académique
il rassemble plus de 4000 hommes et
femmes militaires sur l'avenue des
champs-elysées le traditionnel défilé du
14 juillet c'est dans deux jours un
événement où vous l'imaginez bien un
millimétrée qui nécessite de nombreuses
répétitions les troupes à pied
s'entraîne depuis le début de la semaine
dans les yvelines sur le camp de satory
aurélie ronge les a suivis armées de
terre de l'air marine ou encore
gendarmerie depuis le début de la
semaine à satory tout le monde marche au
pas les répétitions pour le défilé du
14-juillet s'enchaînent sur le site
militaire yvelinois qui présentent
quasiment les mêmes caractéristiques
techniques que les champs elysées dans
les rangs cette année un régiment
habitués le spy basée à valence et qui
revient tout juste du mali y aura
toujours des petites choses qui vont pas
sur les premières répétitions
vous fur et à mesure des heures à mesure
des entraînements individuellement que
collectivement on s'améliore pour
finalement donner une impression
l'impression d'ensemble qui n'est pas la
plus belle possible silence et sérieux
sont de rigueur lorsque le général passe
les troupes en revue
depuis lundi les 4290 militaire qui
descendront à pied la plus belle avenue
du monde répète cet exercice quatre fois
par jour
malgré cette préparation très minutieuse
le sentiment de fierté l'emportent le
capitaine amélie originaire des yvelines
défilera dimanche avec ses hommes avant
de rejoindre dans quelques jours
l'institut des hautes études de défense
nationale véritable honneur de pouvoir
défiler à la tête donc de certains de
mes personnels on pourrait dire donc de
mon unité pour terminer un petit peu
comme on dirait avec panache
7 ce temps de commandement
pour certains ce défilé 2018 sera une
première et prendra même des airs de
réunion de famille un père et son fils
tous deux affectés à la base aérienne
107 de vélizy-villacoublay défileront
ensemble le 14 juillet c'est une fierté
de représenter son pays et puis se sont
armés et de siran content d'être là moi
c'est la deuxième chance elysées c'est
vraiment un plaisir de défiler avec mon
fils je pense que l'information qu'il a
pu suivre sur la base d' apporter le
maximum d'informations je pense qu'ils
soutiennent des défis liés au thème du
défilé cette année fraternité d'armes
sous l'uniforme l'engagement d'une vie
un engagement visible le 14 juillet sur
les champs elysées est les vacances
d'été ont démarré depuis est quasi une
semaine une période de chaleur ou les
moments de fraîcheur sont les bienvenus
à villepreux la piscine municipale a
rouvert depuis le 26 juin chaque année
l'équipement saisonnier est en service
de fin juin à début septembre sur place
de bassins un grand et un d'initiation
un espace gazonné avec transats et
parasols capacité maximum de 300
personnes un site qu'il faut bien sûr
entretenir avant sa réouverture
écoutez ses explications au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
on essaye de faire des travaux un petit
peu tous les ans parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même pour une piscine
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
coût et
donc ça nous coûte à peu près à l'année
130 à 150 mille euros sachant qu'on
rentre en fonction des saisons entre
entre 20 et 40 mille euros de recettes
sur sur la saison l entrée de 5 euros
tarif réduit pour les villes provient
des animations se tiendront sur place
tout l'été une idée de lecture à présent
pour vos vacances d'ailleurs peut-être
sur un transat une saint-quentinoise
laetitia faubert vous propose de plonger
dans les aventures fantastiques d'un
adolescent de 11 ans son nom ouest ferry
deux ouvrages sont déjà sortis et le
troisième tome est attendu pour 10 2019
aurélie ronde et car la vie gens ont
rencontré l'auteur j'ai vécu toute ma
scolarité ici que ça soit manille ou à
montigny au lycée de emilie breteuil et
puis je travaille toujours à saint
quentin et j'ai toute ma famille et mes
amis qui sont à 50 ans si j'étais
vraiment pas très très écriture quand
j'étais au collège
d'ailleurs si jamais mes profs me
reconnaissent ils vont diront on
l'aurait jamais vu écrire celle là donc
voilà parce que j'étais vraiment pas
doué c'est venu en fait d'un seul coup
mes enfants qui m'ont dit maman est ce
que tu peux écrire une histoire
voilà donc au départ je pensais faire
une petite histoire pour mes enfants et
puis qui sait devenu un livre puis un
deuxième et puis l'agefi le troisième si
l'histoire d'un petit garçon et son
meilleur ami qui vivent bains où l'on
peut sembler aux lecteurs parce que je
n'ai pas précisée de ville justement
exprès pour qu'on puisse dire est ce que
c'est la ville d'à côté ce que c'est
plus loin est ce que voilà donc ils sont
ici sur terre et font leur vie comme
tous les enfants qui ont 10 ans et le
jour 2
de son anniversaire donc le jour de ses
11 ans et la planque il fait partie d'un
autre monde
le monde de l'invisible et en fait qu'
un monde magique et qu'ils ont été
exilés sur terre par la faute d'un
dingue comment dire d'un usurpateur qui
a pris la place des souverains le
premier tome j'ai mis à peu près deux
ans à l'écrire parce qu'en fait j'avais
commencé à écrire sur sur un petit
calepin
et le fait d'écrire et puis de le
retranscrire après sur sur pc ça m'a
pris pas mal de temps et pour le
deuxième j'ai fait pareil puisque
j'avais pas le je me mettais sur le pc
ça me faisait page blanche
j'arrivais pas à avancer et des je
prenais mon calepin ça repartait quoi il
ya des adultes qui l'ont lu également et
qui quand ils ont dû le premier attend
dès le 2 maintenance ceux qui ont lu lé
de attendre le 3 donc je dirais qu'il ya
vraiment pas d'âge est la france fans de
pizza nous sommes le deuxième pays qui
en consomment le plus au monde derrière
les états unis mais devant l'italie
normal que des pizzaïolos français
brillent dans les concours
internationaux bonsoir sébastien ses
idoles
bonsoir elle vous est le gérant de la
pizzeria l'authentic à garancière dans
les yvelines vous êtes classé sixième au
championnat du monde de pizza c'était en
juin dernier à naples berceau de la de
la pizza se classer sixième dans un
championnat du monde c'est une fierté
pour vous bah oui oui c'est une grande
fête grande fierté surtout je m'y
attendais pas forcément
donc oui c'est je suis assez content
c'est un championnat qui rassemblait 600
participants tous vous dans votre
catégorie y avait 300 participants
directement mais on était six cents 600
participants de 40 pays et dans ma
spécialité la classique on était trois
sondes anticipons vous le dites une
fierté d'autant plus que la pizza pour
vous c'est quelque chose de tout récent
vous y êtes remis cet hiver à la pizza
ouais c'est ça de depuis novembre mon
j'étais quand même dans le
dans le milieu de la restauration j'ai
commencé par de la cuisine pâtisserie et
puis oui effectivement je suis tombé
dans la pizza par passion et puis bon
cop
qu'est ce qui vous plaît justement dans
la pizza qui est ce qui fait aujourd'hui
que c'est une passion pour vous de faire
des pizzas
la patte toujours le côté restauration
en faire le côté de faire plaisir aux
gens le voilà en plus alors il faut le
préciser pour les téléspectateurs vous
avez réussi le tour de force à naples de
faire aimer aux italiens aux napolitains
une pizza aux poissons ce qui est n'est
pas chose aisée parce que je parle en
connaissance de cause étant d'origine
italienne la pizzas au poisson c'est pas
quelque chose de courant en italie on en
consomme en france aux anchois notamment
mais en italie ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose de courant
exactement il s'est un peu compliqué de
la leur faire manger une pizza aux
poissons j'ai essayé et ça leur a plu
bonne pizza rouge et ils ont aimé et
racontez nous comment s'est déroulé le
concours il a fallu que vous alliez
chercher les produits directement sait
comment ça s'est déroulée cette
compétition du coup
on arrive on est arrivé le samedi et
dimanche sur le lieu de la compétition
d'accord on s'imprégner un peu un peu de
la compétition et du coup on est allé
chercher nos nos ingrédients directement
à naples pour ma part j'ai pris de
poisson directement sur le port de
naples qu'il restait 4 4 rouges et où
j'étais assez content donc après le
on avait un petit appartement où on a pu
justement préparer nos garniture oui la
préparation se faisait sur place
directement la pizza s'cusez directement
sur le web
oui par contre là
on avait nos petites préparations et du
coup on avait un four à bois à
disposition et voilà donc on a préparé
notre pizza devant un jury quatre jurys
et puis injuste de four vous regardez et
qu'est-ce qui a pu vous dire le jury
qu'est ce qu'il ya à fait aimer votre
pizza au jury et une pizza aux poissons
on la rappelle ça c'est une bonne
question parce que j'étais assez assez
stressé je porte pas beaucoup italien né
coup moi je suis reparti directement du
côté de mon faux pour tout nettoyer j'ai
pas vu la réaction du jury c'est pour ça
que c'était vraiment une surprise de
voir mon nom marqué a causé de sixième
donc j'étais assez content une sixième
place après quelques mois d'expérience
seulement dans la pizza vous félicite
pour sa caisse qui fait une bonne pizza
d'après vous sébastien sidon c'est quoi
[Musique]
je pense que c'est 50 50 50 pour cent de
la pâte il faut qu'il soit relativement
légères ou haineuses craquante et puis à
50% aussi de la garniture une bonne
garniture et les bons produits frais une
bonne sauce tomate faisons je leur dis
mais des bons produits frais d'ailleurs
on a pu goûter en rédaction de vos vos
pizzas les les recettes que l'on peut
retrouver dans votre récent ya pas de
pizza au projet parce que c'est quand
même une pizza on imagine qu'il peut
coûter qui pourrait coûter assez cher
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve à la carte de
votre pied derrière beaucoup de choses
d'une pizza par exemple une pizza parme
avec du jambon de parme de la roquette
qu'est-ce que j'ai là la fameuse
margarita donc sauce tomate mozzarella
basilique d'accord et beaucoup de choses
j'ai végétarienne avec des bons produits
le boom de bons légumes vous accordez
une importance oui aux produits que vous
choisissez pour parler pizza oui oui oui
je pense que c'est assez primordial
surtout de nos jours où il ya beaucoup
de concurrence
donc il faut vraiment avoir des bons
choix de produits c'est obligatoire
une dernière question on est en période
de coupe du monde la finale se joue
dimanche france croatie est ce que c'est
une période où les commandes affluent un
peu plus que qu'elle a qu'à l'accoutumée
oui oui oui moi au moins je sais que mon
nombre de commandes a considérablement
augmenté et j'en suis content aussi
après je ne sais pas si c'est l'effet
coupe du monde de foot ou au championnat
d' de pizzas donc l'avenir nous le dira
et en tout cas on peut retrouver les
informations peuvent ou contactez
peut-être pour réserver une table à la
pizzeria l'authentic au numéro de
téléphone va peut-être s'afficher en bas
d'écran ça y est ça s'affiche la pizza l
authentique je rappelle qui est donc
situé à garancière merci sébastien
s'isole d'avoir été avec nous mais je
vous remercie et merci de nombreux
invités et et bravo encore pour votre
sixième place obtenue au championnat du
monde des pizzas c'était à naples en
juin dernier
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal 20 ans cela
fait aujourd'hui vingt ans jour pour
jour que la france a remporté à la coupe
du monde de football c'était le 12
juillet 1998 vous vous en souvenez
sûrement dans trois jours les bleus
peuvent de nouveau gagner le mondial il
rencontre dimanche à 17h en finale la
croatie une rencontre que vous pourrez
suivre sur écran géant dans le coin à
événement exceptionnel la lieu
prestigieux le vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines vous accueille
dès 16h pour encourager les hommes de
didier deschamps à magny les hameaux
ouvre pour l'occasion son café culturel
de l'estaminet vous pourrez encore
suivre les dribbles de keegan bape et au
stadio ou de plaisir et à l'abri blues
de bois d'arcy
enfin la commune de fontenay-le-fleury
elle proposera une retransmission en
plein air dans le parc de la des
meuneries voilà le dernier à 7,8 journal
de la saison touche à sa fin merci de
votre fidélité j'ai été très heureux de
présenter ses 165 édition en votre
compagnie un grand merci en personne aux
personnes en collier ce qui a rendu
possible ce journal l equipe des
monteurs des infographistes et du
webmaster la rédaction bien sûr et une
pensée plus particulière pour camille
lambert et nicolas kirilow vide ça qui
s'envole vers de nouvelles aventures
merci à vous deux et et bonne
continuation et le 7-8 journal revient
dès le lundi 3 septembre à l'antenne bel
été sur tv 78
[Musique]